dieses Bild macht momentan die Runde in
der AFD eine rissige Mauer schon so tief
zerfurcht dass er Einsturz nur noch eine
Frage der Zeit ist und freiwillige Muse
für dieses Bild das AFD la fleißig in
den sozialen Netzwerken Teilen Friedrich
Merz CDU-Chef der im ZDF sommerinterview
dies sagte
es ist jetzt in Thüringen ein Landrat
gewählt worden und natürlich ist das
eine demokratische Wahl das haben wir
doch zu akzeptieren und natürlich muss
in den Kommunalparlamenten dann auch
nach Wegen gesucht werden wie man
gemeinsam die Stadt das Land den
Landkreis gestaltet damit entfachte März
riesen Ärger in seiner CDU und helle
Begeisterung in der AFD ko Parteichefin
Weidel sagte der Süddeutschen Zeitung
die CDU komme nicht umhin das
Kontaktverbot zur AFD aufzuheben die AFD
will mehr und ist bereit für mehr
behauptet sie zumindest im Slogan den
sie sich in ihrem zehnten Jahr verpasst
hat und indem es für sie so gut läuft
wie noch nie in Umfragen klettert sie
Woche für Woche nach oben und im
thüringischen Sonneberg gewann sie
erstmals eine Landratswahl
es zeigt sich auch was es bringt
Brandmauern aufzubauen die Grünen
anzustreichen was machen die Bürger
gerade hier in Thüringen in Sachsen in
Ostdeutschland im Mitteldeutschland die
stellen einen Ausreiseantrag zu AFD und
das ist hier heute
[Applaus]
die AFD strotzt vor Kraft das Prinzip
immer dagegen scheint aufzugehen wir
haben Alleinstellungsmerkmale wir
vertreten die Interessen der Bürger also
wir haben keine Werte geleitete Politik
sondern interessengeleitete Politik wir
stellen uns klar gegen die
Wirtschaftssanktionen gegen Russland
aber auch die zukünftigen Sanktionen die
schon gegen China geplant sind ein
weiteres Alleinstellungsmerkmal der
Verfassungsschutz beobachtet Teile der
AFD als gesichert rechtsextremistisch
etwa den thüringischen Landesverband
sowie den dortigen kurvorsitzenden Björn
höcke zu ihm nach Erfurt reiste
koopertal-chefin Weidel demonstrativer
Schulterschluss und Beweis für höckes
macht jeder interne Widerstand gegen ihn
ist Geschichte
dem Zuspruch in den Umfragen tut dies
keinen Abbruch gleichzeitig aber lehnt
die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung mehr
Einfluss für die AFD ab
43% der Befragten wollen keine
Zusammenarbeit das sind 9% Punkte mehr
als noch im Oktober 2017
33% sind der Meinung die Parteien
sollten von Fall zu Fall entscheiden 17%
sind für eine Zusammenarbeit
die AFD klemmt fest zwischen Umfrage
hoch und Ablehnung Erfolg durch
Radikalisierung für die Partei ist das
stand jetzt Segen und Fluch zugleich
und jetzt ist mir Alice Weidel die
afd-parteivorsitzende aus Magdeburg
zugeschaltet wurde afd-bundesparteitag
heute beginnt einen schönen guten Morgen
Frau Weidel
guten Morgen in den letzten Tagen gab es
zahlreiche Diskussionen um eine
Brandmauer zur AFD CDU-Chef Merz hatte
ja noch mal klargestellt eine
Zusammenarbeit wird es nicht geben und
auch alle anderen Parteien betonen das
jetzt ganz demonstrativ Frau Weidel um
politisch auch ja langfristig gestalten
zu können müssen sie ja irgendwann auch
andere Parteien von sich überzeugen wie
wollen Sie das machen
also zunächst einmal zu dieser
brandmauerdebatte das habe ich ja auch
in meinen reden dargelegt ich halte
diese Debatte für höchstgradig
antidemokratisch wir sind eine
demokratisch gewählte Partei wir binden
Millionen von Wählern und uns derartig
versuchen auszugrenzen ist ohnehin Gott
sei Dank nicht durch haltbar das sehen
wir jetzt innerhalb der CDU die jetzt
ihre Diskussion haben ein wackelkurs von
den Parteivorsitzenden den auch nicht
durchhalten kann und lassen Sie uns mal
sehen wie das nächstes Jahr bei den
Landtagswahlen in Ostdeutschland
aussieht wo wir jetzt schon bei weitem
stärkste Kraft sind deswegen die Frage
wie wollen sie da andere Parteien davon
zu über davon überzeugen mit ihm
zusammen zu arbeiten
über unsere Stärke und über unsere
Programmatik sie können nicht dauerhaft
als CDU darüber reden wir jetzt ja
gerade können sie nicht mit Wahl
verlieren koalieren wie sie das bei den
letzten Landtagswahlen gemacht haben und
da wir mit Abstand bereits stärkste
Kraft sind und auch noch in den Umfragen
zulegen werden davon bin ich zutiefst
überzeugt
sehe ich nicht wie man ohne uns in
irgendeiner Form regieren kann frau
beide das Problem ist dass nicht nur die
Parteien keine zusammenarbeitet wollen
auch die meisten Wähler nicht wir haben
es gerade in unserem Beitrag gesehen
laut aktuellen Umfragen ist die Mehrheit
der Befragten gegen eine Zusammenarbeit
und ein Grund für diese Ablehnung ist
auch der vom Verfassungsschutz als
rechtsextreme eingestufte thüringische
Landesverband unter der Führung von
Björn höcke müssen sie sich von solchen
Strömungen nicht lösen um auch von
bürgerlichen Lager mehr Akzeptanz zu
erhalten
ach wissen Sie dieses framing also so
wie unsere Partei permanent eingerahmt
wird jetzt schon seit zehn Jahren wie
wir nach rechts geschrieben werden und
und und auch das erhalte ich für
Zuschuss bedenklich dass man sich
mitnichten mitnichten mit Entschuldigung
mit nichten mit unserer Programmatik
beschäftigt wir sind zum Beispiel die
einzige Partei die für
direktdemokratische Elemente ist für
Volksabstimmung demokratischer geht es
nicht und ich würde mir wünschen dass
man sich damit auch mal
auseinandersetzen würde mit den Dreien
inhaltlichen Fragen und nicht sage ich
jetzt mal diesen Urteil des
Verfassungsschutzes der ja mit nicht in
eine unabhängige Behörde ist
dass sie den Verfassungsschutz als nicht
unabhängig empfinden das Argument kennen
wir von ihnen aber dazu gab es auch ein
ein Urteil des Verfassungsgericht Köln
dass diese Einstufung bestätigt und das
ist also kein framing das sozusagen nur
von meiner Seite aus betrieben wird hier
in dieser Frage aber sie wollen über
Inhalte sprechen deshalb Stärke mir
gerne über Inhalte ihre Frau Weidel in
den nächsten punkten denn auch wenn wir
gerade bei Björn höcke waren da gibt es
möglicherweise auch inhaltliche
Differenzen jetzt am Wochenende und
damit kommen wir jetzt zum Thema EU und
ich möchte zitieren wir streben daher
die geordnete Auflösung der EU an das
lese ich im Leitantrag für ein
Parteiprogramm für die Europawahl davon
ist die Parteispitze jetzt wieder
abgerückt die Forderung sei durch ein
Zitat redaktionelles Versehen in den
Text geraten da frage ich mich natürlich
wie kann das sein dass eine so radikale
Forderung in den Leitantrag Gerät obwohl
die Parteispitze eigentlich dagegen ist
oder waren sie ursprünglich auch dafür
naja wir als AFD wir sagen ganz klar
dass der Nationalstaat das Gefäß das
richtige Gefäß für eine Demokratie ist
denn nur in einem Nationalstaat kann
eine gesellschaftliche Debatte geführt
werden auch nur in den Nationalstaaten
sitzen gewählte Volksvertreter und
dementsprechend kann die EU mit ihrem
demokratiedefiziert mit ihren
ubiquitären demokratiedefiziten es sind
ja mehrere nicht die gesetzgebende
Gewalt sein für die Nationalstaaten
Europas das ist ganz klar beide sind sie
jetzt noch mal ganz konkret für oder
gegen sie glauben verstehen also ich
weiß ich wiederhole gerne die Frage ich
hatte gefragt machen Sie es bitte ganz
konkret sind sie für oder gegen die
Auflösung der EU
das habe ich ihn gerade beantwortet der
Nationalstaat ist das Gefäß für eine
funktionierende Demokratie wir sind für
einen kompetenzrückbau der Europäischen
Union die so nicht funktioniert und sich
immer weiter aufbläht und genau diese
Frage wird auf dem Parteitag diskutiert
gut dann möchte ich einen zum Schluss
einen Blick noch auf die innenpolitische
Lage der AFD werfen ihren Vorsitzender
alexander gauland hat zuletzt in einem
Interview gesagt die Zustimmung in der
Bevölkerung sei nicht in erster Linie
Verdienst der AFD sie verdankt sich den
Fehlern der Anderen so sein es Zitat und
deswegen sei es nicht realistisch eine
Kanzlerkandidatur aufzurufen wie
kommentieren Sie das bleiben Sie dabei
dass die AFD für die Bundestagswahl 2025
ein Kandidaten aufstellt
also erstmal ähm wird in unserer Partei
Meinungsvielfalt gepflegt jeder kann
seine Meinung sagen ich sage ganz klar
die AFD unsere Partei die in den
Umfragen sich stabilisiert hat vor der
Kanzlerpartei SPD zweitstärkste Kraft
bundesweit ist nur noch 4% hinter der
CDU muss eine Führungsanspruch stellen
und den stellen sie nur mit Aufstellung
eines Kanzlerkandidaten soweit die
Parteivorsitzende der AFD beim heute
beginnt eine Parteitag in Magdeburg
Alice war das herzlichen Dank für das
Interview
danke schön